herr liefers 10 legten gerade ihr
eindruck sie sind nah dran wie sehr
fördert wirtschaftlicher niedergang
möglicherweise politische radikalität in
meinem freundeskreis überhaupt nicht
also ich glaube das ist einfach eine
generelle frage der eigenen lenker hat
vielleicht auch das eigene charakter ist
vielleicht doch der eigenen anfälligkeit
versuche ist also niemand in meinem
freundeskreis wird die gleiche oder
internet noch mal die skype verwendung
also in meinem freundeskreis wird
niemand radikal weil wir gerade nicht
weiß wer seine miete bezahlen soll
aber traurig schon und ratlos und das
sollte jemand sein in diesem land und
die sax nochmal der aufwand den eine
regierung betreibt leuten zu erklären
warum monaten und monat wurde das ziel
flatten ich das immer noch so eine lange
alleine auf die prognose ist könnte
wieder losgeht
obwohl es gar kein tatsächlicher länder
ist darauf gibt es noch mal los geht
also auch da gibt es experten die ganz
anderer meinung sind als die im moment
gerade so die light my number ist das
muss man leuten erklären und das muss
man auch wissenschaftlich tut und das
muss man auch menschlich tun und am ende
ist es eine frage wie wir alle leben
wollen und was so ein grundgesetz und
was eine freiheit in so einer
gesellschaft von der bedeutung hat wie
sehr wir die unterordneten zum beispiel
einem infektionsschutz
das ist eine diskussion kann man nicht
einfach bestimmen